Hey you, so nice of you to join
us! We want to tell you about
something that changed kurzgesagt forever.
Kurzgesagt started out as a small-scale
passion project. But creating animated
science videos that are free for everyone,
doesn’t pay the bills – DAMN YOU reality!
In order to make ends meet we had to take
on “real jobs” during the day and create
kurzgesagt videos at night. It was tough
but our dream of inspiring people
all around the world kept us going.
Then in 2016 everything changed.
Kurzgesagt’s founder, Philipp Dettmer
had an idea. He wanted to create something
inspiring that would extend beyond the
digital YouTube cosmos. Something tangible.
Something that would represent kurzgesagt’s
view of the world and our belief in
humanity’s potential for greatness.
His idea: the kurzgesagt Human Era Calendar.
It establishes a new year zero to include all
people and cultures around the world. This
new year zero, roughly 12,000 years ago,
signifies a time when humans first started
working together on a larger scale,
laying the foundation for modern society
and eventually our future ahead of us.
The first Human Era Calendar was a
huge success, it sold out within a
few hours and inspired thousands of birbs
around the globe. Every year since then,
we’ve created a new edition of the Human
Era Calendar – each one more spectacular
and successful than the last. It has
enabled us to grow our team, improve
our video quality and research standards, and
still release our videos for free for everyone.
This year’s calendar is extra special.
Join us as we conduct a series of space
experiments to see how they would affect the
development of life. What would a creature
living near an orange dwarf look like?
Could life still exist after a supernova
explosion? And what the hell is this?
Join us in 12,024 and find out. And
of course you can also use it to plan
humanity's next steps towards greatness.
To celebrate what may be our most
glorious calendar yet, we've prepared
a few spectacular limited deals for you.
Thank you so much for being a part of our
story and for coming together every
year to make all of this possible!